drop the mic what's it all about I like
what she tells you but I still eat the
stuff all right
drop the mic is this a battle rap show
where we pit celebrities against each
other kind of like a fish out of water
thing it's like battle of the Network
Stars but what mics you know so you may
see Jerry Springer go up against Maury
Povich if we're feeling that way you
know basically that's the the premises
those are teams now is each you guys
have a team like how does it work no
there's no teams okay
no we co-host together okay yeah and
then the contestants come on and you
know we'll have people come on from the
same TV show or like people that are
really friends and know each other or
people that have nothing to even
remotely do with each other
and they go up in front of our audience
and they do it out
they do it so is their segments though
cause it's half an hour so I am do the
part as far as um y'all ready for the
battle let's go Haley handles the hard
part where you got to go back then talk
to these freaks like the interviews
backstage with like battles a show so
we'll have an opening battle and we'll
have the closing yeah and I'm joking by
the way but yeah she does the the
interview stuff and some of the
wraparound stuff you know the and and
yeah I'm just did it yeah so I mean how
did this choke at James Corden obviously
did something a segment how did this
kind of come about what do you mean you
know the backstory like he how did this
come about with you go back Tory that's
funny you said that um he he does
sickness at the end of The Late Late
Show right and um they came up with the
drop the Mike concept where he would
battle his guests and it happened to be
Anne Hathaway that night and when he did
it with n Hathaway that was supposed to
be it swarmers seen it and said okay I
get to choose what segment I want to do
at the end I'm gonna do what she did and
he wrote his own verse so then it just
turned into a thing snow balled they
called me asked me if I'd do it say yeah
they called her ass if she do it she
said maybe and then we have you guys met
before had we had it no
chemistry seems great though you guys
see myself while we get genuine so you
don't think people would be intimidated
rapping in front of method yeah it's
gonna be they are they all are
have you guys filmed anybody yet as
anyone have you guys started taking at
all seven episodes already okay and how
did those go good we had Vanessa Hudgens
Rob Gronkowski Gina Rodriguez voice -
man Rascal Flatts uh sure Anthony
Anderson we've had really really Chrissy
Mets people so far
I love Chrissy was what was the
highlight one for you guys so far like
what's one that you'd like people to
look out for
I loved Rascal Flatts and boys to men
yeah that's a good battle that was
really funny plus it was only usually
just one on once a three-on-three type
of thing a group kind of battles to
change to one had around to themselves
so you got the instead of being in the
group setting they got to shine as
individuals which I posed oh are you
guys making personal calls having their
friends on I want to but I don't want to
step on any toes plus I want to see
exactly what kind of guests they're
looking for because most of the people
that I know that aren't rappers rap but
I also feel like as the show comes out
there will be people that come to us
being like this is dope I really want to
do this and that will be interesting to
see - cos just kind of how he said David
Schwimmer he was like oh I want to be a
part of this cuz it's dope and I thought
it was really fun and I think that's
gonna start happening how are you guys
gonna about balance this was so much
going on I mean you have movies coming
out you're obviously doing movies and
acting and business stuff how you guys
balancing the schedules of doing oh come
on you film you know it only takes what
good show maybe two or three days to
shoot a show but it's the commitment of
being there a lot of times it's not
necessary the time it's like I have to
be in this place at this time to get
this done every time you lock into like
a shock I'm out I mean we lock them out
well you know we block out the time
obviously to do it but
you know I when I even came into screen
test for the show I flew straight from
from payroll I did test for the show
yeah because you know I've never done
this before
so I came straight from Fashion Week I
was in there I was trying this thing
that was very new to me and when you
just keep keep running
that's it she's young so I mean like I
can see the end it appeared and I'm
inching up on it slowly but it's coming
I know it's coming speaking of coming a
CBS show is coming out yeah to do that
was a weird pun because they know the
subject matter it was not intended I
know
[Music]
um what could you expect yeah yeah I
mean it's exactly what it is it's about
the porn industry in the 70s all right
where it kind of got its start at with
two brothers all right Franco plays the
two brothers because of course there
aren't enough parts out there so you had
to play two individuals in the same
anyway Maggie Gyllenhaal oh she plays a
call girl who's trying to transit I mean
she wants something more for like
basically I'm gonna give you the whole
thing but it's the start of the
seventies porn industry and the seedy
aspect of what 42nd Street was what's
this seedy aspect let me write that down
are you enjoying it um we're faded we've
been finished filming all four well yeah
it was fun while we were filming to have
because if you've seen the trailer
you've seen now I'm fully decked out
long hair tight sue
it was a kick and oceans eight oceans
eight yes hardly how many permit agency
uh okay so they had some people come in
and do camp I'm not like you know
alongside Rihanna and oceans a let's not
stretch the truth here we we a couple
even some friends of mine we all did
some cameos for oceans eight which so
cool
the the director is phenomenal he um for
for me it was like the feeling of being
on such a big production and a big set
it you know it's not something I'm I've
done yet in terms of film and it kind of
being there of course I've grown up
doing that and I'm used to it but it
being for me or something that I was
specifically involved in it made me
definitely like catch the bug because I
was like oh this is so dope and I love
this like feeling in this energy don't
look out for my I appreciate it that's
what's on my mind
you